principalmente el acceso total a la
píldora abortiva mifepistone
suspendiendo la decisión de un tribunal
inferior de Texas que dejaba sin piso la
aprobación del gobierno de la píldora
abortiva utilizada en más de la mitad de
los abortos en Estados Unidos El juez
Samuel alito accedió a la solicitud del
gobierno de restaurar hasta el miércoles
de la próxima semana el acceso total a
la píldora y solicitó además información
adicional para el próximo martes
concretamente el gobierno de biden y El
fabricante de medicamentos danco
laboratoris instaron a la corte a no
cuestionar la experiencia de la
administración de drogas y alimentos de
Estados Unidos fda que se basó en datos
de docenas de ensayos clínicos cuando
aprobó la mifepristone hace 23 años y
que ahora un juez nombrado por Trump
está cuestionando según el gobierno
dejar el fallo del juez de Texas en su
lugar crearía confusión e incertidumbre
para los proveedores de servicios de
aborto y tendría consecuencias
devastadoras para la capacidad de la
industria farmacéutica y para que esta
industria pueda llevar nuevos
medicamentos al mercado la Corte Suprema
también podría reprogramar rápidamente
una sesión informativa completa y un
argumento oral para revisar el caso
antes del receso de verano de la corte